Paul is with us in California hey Paul
how are you yes there are you better
than I deserve what's up thank you for
taking my call I just want to first off
say my wife and I were out of debt
because of your teachings and we agree
with you and we follow your teachings
and as want to say thank you on that
front
um but something strikes me last couple
weeks and a little bit ago kind of like
stuff that you've been saying about
inequality of wealth or went on I just
kind of have you actually like gods and
you know I was like I need to talk to
this guy you know what you feel like
what's your position on that because I'm
really struggling it's not that I'm a
socialist by any means nor am i a
capitalist by any means now given the
state of our economy and it's kind of
like where will we venture out to it's
just I don't know I hear you say certain
things that I know kind of spending
means to be honest because I look at
this stuff as you know inequality of
wealth and it's not that we feel
entitled but I think this capitalism has
gone so far to the point where it did in
1929 now the people how to respond in a
real way throughout the 30s because it
seems like if capitalism doesn't have
the safety valve we get to where we are
today and I think a lot of people feel
that way and it's coming back and when
we hear like great people like you kind
of like I don't know kind of top up top
ilysm to the point where it's like you
know it's not Jesus you know it's like I
don't know I just did you hear me say we
can happen alizarin was Jesus honest no
no I mean I don't mean it literally like
I'm saying you know to the point where
it's basically three forms of economic
thought and when it comes down to it
no there's capitalism there's socialism
there's communism you're aware of that
right yeah
okay and communism of course one extreme
end of the spectrum capitalism on the
other end the spectrum socialism hovers
in the middle dangerously precariously
and you're obviously a person of faith a
Christian right yes okay and so I am too
and so as I've studied economics from an
academic viewpoint and then try to align
that with my faith and I think okay what
is the best form of economics because
none of them can be exclusively
supported scripturally correct okay but
which is the form
that is best for the most people right
and that that's what I'm after how are
the motor people served and the form
that I've landed on because of that is
what the theologian Novak called
sanctified capitalism which is
capitalism that does not have a moral
component to it is not really capitalism
it is more like anarchy right so how do
we as a society kind of like address you
know these issues on a higher I mean
because obviously you know capitalism
without a safety belt as a whole I mean
I get it individually what you're saying
right sure safety valve is the answer
safety valve sounds like a government
intrusion to me the safety valve I would
be looking for would be the moral would
be moral integrity right let me since
you know glass-steagall when I was in
effect I mean we don't have any pause
for 50 years and all of a sudden we
start deregulate and now we have these
massive problems people getting you know
I mean it's just getting one obviously
and I as a soul soul way people getting
what what did you didn't say anything
you just said people getting people
getting what well begging can call you
well I mean you think they'll talk about
capitalism competitiveness I hear that
from like well why don't we get
competitiveness back in the banking
system where I deposit my money how
about you don't touch it yeah you know
they don't they won't have that and
there's this anymore
how about it's not just saying what do
you think has caused the inequality of
wealth what rule I personally I I really
do believe the extreme capitalism in
this country with corporate America I
that what do you mean by corporate
America with corporate America I mean in
2009 Verizon Pfizer these guys they pay
any taxes how do you how do you not I
think some of them you got to check back
how does that work I like people let me
ask you this if a corporation which is
not a human it's an entity if it pays
taxes and you as a customer of Verizon
as an example or Exxon or whomever if
they paid if they paid no taxes you you
don't believe that in the event that
someone that was running the corporation
that was a reasonable person at granted
there are greedy jerks out there but I
don't think they're the majority like
you do but the I
the corporate taxation is reflected in
the price of goods in other words if
Verizon has to pay taxes a higher tax
rate then it's going to be reflected in
the higher cost of goods let me give you
another example okay the company that I
love the corporate the company that I
own is a corporation and I 100 percent
of it it's incorporated so I guess I'm
corporate America I don't I don't think
you meant that I'm evil corporate
America like you were aiming at but I am
a corporation now if you raise the taxes
on that company on your basis then do
you not think the cost of a Total Money
Makeover book or the cost of a financial
piece kit for you to attend the class is
going to go up well of course there can
goes up so really who paid the taxes the
consumer yeah
and so this I know that you're going to
tax corporate America sir is mythology
it's always passing we can support
America thirty eight thirty fifty forty
every tax rate factor but it's passed
through you can see we have a class's
inflation it causes inflation that's
right in economy them it causes
inflation inflation is on a thriving
economy if your if your cost of gasoline
doubles but but Exxon got their taxes
doubled how did you win and how did that
scatter that prevent wealth inequality
by but what about as a social I mean as
a social standpoint I like doesn't
matter social networking about the
social standpoint is you're not
redistribute you're talking about
yourself though like you pay the taxes
for Exxon in the cost of a higher gallon
of gas and that went to the government
they screwed up the management of it and
two cents on the dollar makes it back
out into the economy and you call that a
social program no I'm not saying that
I'm the same why is it that these
companies don't pay their fair share and
we have to pay don't pay their fair
share son I just explained it to you you
pay it shouldn't pay you pay it it's
passed through you pay it it's in the
cost of goods we pay you PO really so so
really we're not we're not getting a
deal at Walmart you're right you're
really not listen the cost
of any corporate taxes are built into
the cost of goods you just said that a
minute ago we do so we're paying your
payers axis you're paying the total so
how was the wealth redistributed I'm
missing this it didn't get redistributed
no it's clearly not getting rich you
didn't how that's what I'm saying well
clearly when you raise the taxes on
Walmart on Home Depot on Verizon on
Exxon the wealth does not get
redistributing the tax it's just paying
your taxes well they're not they're not
dodging taxes really they are really you
really think those companies are all
operating illegally are you really that
nice a couple years ago they let Pfizer
bring money back into the country and
they follicle we're gonna being
worthless today if they call they do is
buy more shares than a mythical day huh
who's the mythical babe they let Pfizer
who's they the shareholders that the
executive Sharia law allowed it yes okay
yeah so Kaiser yes I totally agree yes
okay so hey Mac so yeah you know your
the problem is is you're looking for a
boogeyman that doesn't exist honey they
just don't ever but now I do my own
personal life I follow your I believe I
know but you want there to be an evil
out there that's causing wealth
inequality and my point is there's not
an evil out there that it no it's not
but there is we're all the things you
got I just defeated it's not there okay
it's just simply my way thanks for
taking my con yeah I didn't really want
me like I said I I like you Ida say I
don't want to get an argument yeah I
just clearly just want to look position
and clearly I know your position now
that's all I mean it what you're what
hard to figure that out a long time ago
because it's out there every day and see
the problem it this is the problem right
here with this whole wealth inequality
movement there's no there's no logic in
the arguments and Paul being a young guy
has just believed what all his friends
say and it's there's this mythical vague
there's this mythical boogeyman these
mythical corporate America whose
corporate America it's you by the way
it's who hires you to this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you